as a preparation for more complex and
more difficult models we will start by
looking at the simplest model that there
is that involves a linear relation and
normal random variables the specifics of
the model are as follows there's an
unknown parameter modeled as a random
variable theta that we wish to estimate
what we have in our hands is theta plus
some additive noise W and this sum is
our observation X the assumptions that
we make are that theta and W are normal
random variables and to keep the
calculations simple we assume that
they're standard normal random variables
furthermore we assume that theta and W
are independent of each other according
to the Bayesian program inference about
theta is essentially the calculation of
the posterior distribution of theta if I
tell you that the observation capital X
takes on a specific value little X to
calculate this posterior distribution we
invoke the appropriate form of the Bayes
rule we have the prior of theta it's a
standard normal now we need to figure
out the conditional distribution of x
given theta what is it if I tell you
that the random variable capital theta
takes on a specific value little theta
then in that conditional universe our
observation is going to be that specific
value of theta which is our little theta
plus the noise term capital W this is
the relation that holds in the
conditional universe where we are told
the value of theta now W is independent
of theta so even though I have told you
the value of theta the distribution of W
does not change it is still a standard
normal so X is a standard normal plus a
constant theta what that does is that it
changes the
mean of the normal distribution but it
will still be a normal random variable
so in this conditional universe X is
going to be a normal random variable
with mean equal to theta and with
variance equal to the variance of W
which is equal to one so now we know
what this distribution is and we can
move with the calculation of the
posterior so we have the denominator
term which I'm writing here and then we
have the density of theta since it is a
standard normal it takes the form of a
constant we do not really care about the
value of that constant what we care
really is the term on the exponent and
then we have the conditional density of
x given theta which is a normal with
these parameters and therefore it takes
the form C e to the minus 1/2
it's a density in X and so up here we
have X minus the mean of that density
but the mean is equal to theta squared
and this is the final form now what we
notice here is that we have a few
constant terms another term that depends
on X and then a quadratic in theta so we
can write all this as some function of X
and then e to the negative of some
quadratic in theta now when we're doing
inference we are given the value of x so
let us fix a particular value of little
pecks and concentrate on the dependence
on theta so with X being fixed this is
just a constant and as a function of
theta it's e to the minus something
quadratic in theta and we recognize that
this is a normal PDF so we conclude that
the posterior distribution of faith
given our observation is normal since it
is normal the expected value of this
conditional PDF will be the same as the
peak of that PDF and this would be our
point estimate of theta in particular if
we use either the map maximum a
posteriori probability or the list min
squares estimator which is defined as
the conditional expectation of theta
given the observation that we have made
so this conditional expectation is just
the mean of this posterior distribution
it is also the peak of that posterior
distribution so let us find what the
peak is to find the peak we focus on the
exponent term which is ignoring the
minus sign the exponent term is this one
and to find the peak of the distribution
we need to find the place where this
exponent term is smallest to find out
when this term is smallest we take its
derivative with respect to theta and set
it equal to 0 the derivative of this
term is theta the derivative of this
term is theta minus X we set this to
zero and when we solve this equation we
find two theta equal to X therefore
theta is equal to x over two and so we
conclude from here that the peak of the
distribution occurs when theta is equal
to x over two and this is our estimate
of theta so our estimate takes into
account that we believe that theta is 0
on the average but also takes into
account the observation that we have
made and comes up with a value that's in
between our prior mean which was 0 and
the observation which is little X so
this is what the estimates are if we
want to talk about estimators
which are now random variables what
would they be the estimator is a random
variable that takes this value whenever
capital X takes the value of little X
therefore it's the random variable which
is equal to capital X over 2 this is a
relation between random variables this
is a corresponding relation between
numbers if you are given a specific
value for a little X how special is this
example it turns out that the same
structure of the solution shows up even
if we assume that theta and W are
independent normal random variables but
with some general means and variances
you should be able to verify on your own
by repeating the calculations that we
just carried out that the posterior
distribution of theta will still be
normal and since it is normal the peak
of the distribution is the same as the
expected value so the expected value or
least mean squares estimator coincides
with the maximum a posteriori
probability estimator and finally
although this formula will not be
exactly true there will be a similar
formula for the estimators namely the
estimator will turn out to be a linear
function of the measurements we will see
that these conclusions are actually even
more general than that and this is what
makes it very appealing to work with
normal random variables and linear
relations